hey guys Pete here this will be my
watchman episode 8 trailer breakdown the
episode is titled a God walks into a bar
the god is dr. Manhattan the bar is from
the scene in the first half of this
trailer and the whole thing is a play on
Angela's last name which is a bar the
reason why doing these trailer
breakdowns has been fun is because up
until now they've been very generous in
packing a lot of info into each one but
this one's different
we have a bunch of different story
threads converging on the end game and
in this trailer we only get a look at
two scenes so I'll look at those first
and then after that I'll talk about
theories where things are heading for
the other characters as we approach the
season finale this week's trailer opens
with the scene of the blue hand reaching
down to pick up the dr. Manhattan mask
which has showed up in several of the
preseason trailers now we have an idea
of what's going on here this is in fact
dr. Manhattan returning to earth it's in
Saigon in the US state of Vietnam and it
must have happened in 2009 or sometime
before that the date comes from the
medical document for Cal in this week's
PD files it's dated December 23rd 2009
and we can imagine that this would be
when Angela and dr. Manhattan put their
plan in motion to hide him as a normal
man in the next shot we see him from
behind pulling the mask on in episode 7
we saw that during the BBN celebration
people paint themselves blue to
celebrate and this makes for a perfect
opportunity for him to blend into the
crowd he left earth at the end of the
comic and no one has heard from him
since as far as we know so him showing
up on the street in saigon would be a
big deal akin to like Jesus rolling into
town we see the be bien de sign in front
of him as he puts on the mask BBN day is
interesting since we can imagine that
this would be the anniversary of
Angela's parents dying back in 1987
inside the bar we find Angela sitting
alone wearing her Saigon police uniform
she looks deep in thought and probably
sad dr. Manhattan approaches and buys
two beers from the bartender as we hear
their conversation and voice over as far
as what we hear he starts with I love
you Angela responds we just met when did
you fall in love with me I was already
in love with you before you even saw me
I don't experience the concept of
for this relates to the way dr.
Manhattan experiences time I'm guessing
they're gonna give an explanation of
this in the episode so I don't want to
get too far off the track and talk about
this for people who never read the comic
book the fourth issue explains it really
well as its from his point of view
essentially everything that has happened
to him or will happen to him he can
experience all at the same time so he
can jump back and forth through any
event that happens throughout his
existence the reason I don't want to get
into it too deeply here is that I don't
want to spend a lot of time explaining
it because I could I do think they will
do that on the show this week but it's
something if you haven't read the comic
to put in the back of your mind that his
concept of time is totally foreign to
how we experience it she goes on to say
so there's no moment he says moment and
she says a moment when you realized I'm
in love after that line the voice
changes and we hear what we recognize as
cow's voice say this is the moment I
just told you that you can't save me and
you're going to try anyway there's a lot
of stuff going on in these few
back-and-forth lines the first thing was
that experience of time overall this
feels like a first date from Angela's
point of view it is their first meeting
but dr. Manhattan already knows how it's
going to go and what's going to happen
afterwards from the trailer it appears
that dr. Manhattan returned to earth for
this meeting I don't think we can say
that for sure
it's definitely possible he came back
for something else and this is something
that happens while he's there what
stands out to me after watching this
thing over and over is how relaxed
angela is singing across from what could
best be described as a god it says a lot
about the character development they did
leading up to this moment and I think
that's what's gonna make this
interaction so interesting is that she's
not a normal person
she's already been through a lot we
don't know what's happened to her over
the last 20 years or so since we saw her
as a child but at least from the little
bit we see in the trailer she's not
freaked out by the situation after the
reveal last week that cow was dr.
Manhattan the first big question that
comes up is why is he hiding as Angela's
husband in an interview with The
Hollywood Reporter Lindelof explained
the decisions the writers made in
relation to that he said so how could
dr.
hatton a man with the power of God be in
service of Angela's story as opposed to
the other way around based on his past
and all the tropes of greco-roman
mythology the answer was intuitive love
and you might be sitting there rolling
your eyes the secret ingredient is love
but the base on his past part tracks
with what we know about dr. Manhattan
from the original comic the way he
experiences time turns out to be the
reason why he loses his interest in
humans to oversimplify it he's lost the
ability to be surprised there be scared
or anything else he basically knows
everything that's going to happen and he
can't change it so he's just basically
going through the motions of doing the
things that he has to do and this causes
the disconnect I brought this up in my
episode recap when Laurie mentions the
thermodynamic miracles to Angela because
that is what brought him back to earth
the first time part of adrian veidt's
plan was to get dr. Manhattan to leave
Earth so he could go through with his
plan
drop the squid on New York and save
humanity in his mind from the coming
nuclear war dr. Manhattan goes to Mars
at that point he's there for a while and
he brings Laurie and his connection to
her and the fact that her existence is
so statistically improbable she is a
thermodynamic miracle and his mind
that's what gets him to come back to
earth the website Nerdist wrote a really
good write-up about this I'll put a link
to that in the description along with
the link to the Lindelof interview and
Hollywood Reporter so you can get a
better idea where they were coming from
when they made these decisions so yeah
that part tracks for me the interesting
thing the mystery that's still there is
what brought him to earth in the first
place how they handle that is what's
going to make this either really
interesting or where it could possibly
miss the mark I'll come back to that
after we talk about the second half of
the trailer in between there's a bumper
that has only two episodes left and we
see a flashback to Angela removing the
device from Cal's forehead we see that
the real dr. Manhattan comes back out
and then the second half of the trailer
is essentially picking up with the
seventh cavalry showing up at her house
there's a shootout we see and the only
real big question here I mean obviously
Zillah could be killed it's a gunfight
they wouldn't have any problem with
killing her at this point that just
feels unlikely but the big mystery is
how did these guys plan on stopping dr.
Manhattan initially they thought it was
Cal so are they thinking that they're
gonna trap him as Cal and what's gonna
happen when they find out he's back to
his super-powered self we refer to dr.
Manhattan as a God because he has
godlike powers he's not you can't kill
him so I'm really curious to see if the
seventh Cavalry have a plan for catching
the actual dr. Manhattan or if this
whole idea of her waking him up has
changed the calculus there we know
they've been stockpiling synthetic
lithium watch batteries and they have a
transporter we don't know if it's part
of the plan to catch dr. Manhattan or if
those items are just related to the
contraption they're building at their
hideout the best guess on how they know
he was hiding his cowl is that he
revealed himself in some way during the
white night we saw a 7k member standing
over Angela with a shotgun and he's
never mentioned later when Crawford is
in the hospital with her I imagine what
we don't understand about that night
holds the clues to answer that question
how they plan to capture dr. Manhattan
how they plan to turn Keene into him and
why they keep showing us that they're
using equipment with the true logo on it
or all things that remain to be seen a
lot of the conversation I've seen has
gone back and forth about who will
actually play dr. Manhattan we hear the
voice change clearly from the first half
of the trailer to the second but I can't
say with 100% certainty that it's not
the same actor just altering his voice
or the voice being altered my initial
take was that there would be a different
actor because the voices sound different
one that plays dr. Manhattan that guy
gets turned into cow and then who knows
what the body will look like after he
wakes back up but if you listen it's
possible that the same actor is being
used throughout let me know in the
comments what you guys think about that
there's a theory that dr. Manhattan
created by its prison and the Phillips
and Crookshanks clone people have
speculated that these were made to be
copies of Jon Osterman and his first
girlfriend in the comic Janey Slater
kind of a God making man in his own
image situation that led to people
guessing that Tom Mison who plays mr.
Phillips would play dr. Mann
but this promo photo they released where
you can see his whole body doesn't look
like him in my opinion it doesn't mean
the theory is wrong but we'll have to
wait and see who's gonna actually be
playing dr. Manhattan when he arrives so
as far as theories go it's not a big
stretch to think that Looking Glass is
going to come back we know there's a
missing Rorschach mask which leads to
the idea that he's either gonna save
Laurie over at the JCPenney
or he'll be at this shootout at Angela's
house and he'll play a part in that
somehow as far as endgame theories I'm
at the point where I feel like if there
are credible clues then we have to lean
towards thinking they're pointing us in
a direction the first two reveals were
the kind of things that even when you
heard it they could feel far-fetched as
it turns out both things make a whole
lot of sense and they make for a good
story once you know the whole story of
how that was inserted into what they
were doing so when I first heard the
theory that Adrian Veidt was trapped
inside the statue that didn't sound like
it would be true after learning what
we've learned I kind of think that's
probably what's going on same goes with
him being Lady Truths father
pre-seasoned me wouldn't have thought
that was a possibility at all based on
what we know about Adrian Veidt from
reading the comic but based on
everything we've seen in the show it
sure seems like there's a very good
chance that he is lady trues father I
feel pretty good that if that's what
they had in mind then they'll make it
all make sense the same thing goes with
dr. Manhattan it's hard to imagine that
he spent the last 10 years hiding as
someone's husband in a way that he
didn't know what was going on at all he
basically lost his identity to become a
regular human when they fill in the rest
of the details I think it's going to
probably make sense so all of these
things that have been sticking around
Veidt crashing down on the farm that
true bought that's probably the case
there's probably more to the story
him being in the statue definitely
possible and him being the father of
lady true almost for sure because the
only other real candidate would be the
comedian and I don't know how that's
supposed to happen where he's gonna come
back I definitely like bite better if
one of them's gonna show up for sure as
for a bite as far as this prison who
made it how he ended up there and how he
will eventually return to Tulsa it's all
pretty confusing the last
he was seen in public was 2007 the last
time dr. Manhattan was dr. Manhattan was
2009 we know he's on Europa and a
regular spacecraft that takes about six
years to get there and we're fully
expecting him to return by 2019 all of
that gets a little bit more confused
because lady true mentioned that she had
created some kind of different
propulsion which may change that travel
time and you see it's just a big mess I
kind of feel like he has to be put there
by dr. Manhattan even though I like that
idea less because of the travel time on
one hand it could make sense that he was
transported there by dr. Manhattan dr.
Manhattan went into hiding and now he's
stuck and that's why he's making this
sign that says save me D D being
daughter I've read and reread all the PD
filed documents trying to make all the
dates work out and I didn't have an aha
moment where I was like oh yes he
obviously left at this point this pins
down who sent him and how he got back in
so I just leaned towards dr. Manhattan
and putting him there because he had to
get there quickly and lady true bringing
him back all the other details are up in
the air we'll have to wait and see so
I'm gonna leave it there there's a lot
of other good theories going around but
those are the ones I feel like are
probably gonna play out based on clues
that have been hidden throughout the
story lady true and her end game is
pretty much a mystery still she's going
to do something that's supposed to make
the world a better place
we're probably gonna be left wondering
if it did that or not
probably has something to do with that
big clock that she's building probably
has something to do with the TVs that
she gave everybody probably has
something to do with memories probably
has something to do with mind control
technology but we'll have to wait and
see let me know in the comments which
theories you like which ones you think
you're gonna turn out to be true we only
have two episodes left so how do you
think this thing is going to end please
like the video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already thanks for watching I will talk
to you soon